when running Barefoot most experts and
proponents agree that using a forefoot
strike is preferable this allows the
feet and knees to absorb the impact like
a spring however this is less clear-cut
when walking some people argue that the
same logic applies the forefoot strike
or midfoot strike means the knee is less
locked out on impact and the foot is
closer to the center of gravity
the only problem is that there isn't
much evidence to back this up not only
do many barefoot cultures still walk
with a heel strike but it appears we
have anatomical adaptations that favor
the heel strike for example when the
heel touches the floor this triggers a
reflex that engages the anterior
tibialis the shin muscle slows and
controls the foot's downward motion
which is not to say that you can't use a
more gentle heel touch as you lower your
foot and bring your feet closer to your
body with slightly shorter strides what
do you think ultimately what works for
one person might be different from what
works from someone else
I'd love to hear your ideas
bye for now